hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
uh january
no june 20th
[ __ ] am i talking about june 20th got a
little heat stroke here
ah geez keep the ginger out of the
[ __ ] pool there
i'm doing this podcast on father's day
yeah
father's day man i got home for father's
day i had a wonderful trip out east
uh by the way update on that bird
from uh the podcast on thursday when i
came when i was done with the podcast
it was gone
when i came out to my garage it was a
little
little bird on the [ __ ] ground
and i'm walking up to him was like
leaning to the side like a boat taking
on water little [ __ ] right
i actually debated just stepping on him
so he wouldn't be eaten alive by [ __ ]
insects
but it's a bird i'm not a veterinarian
what am i gonna do stick him in my shirt
pocket like i'm on [ __ ] little house
in the prairie i got a podcast to do but
i left it alone
so i you know went to the garage i did
my podcast and when i came out lo and
behold
he was gone
now
i live in a desert so for all i know
some reptile [ __ ] grabbed the thing
i have no idea i think i would have
heard something
i don't know those reptiles are [ __ ]
slithery little creepy [ __ ]
i really don't like reptiles you know i
am like
i'm donald trump when it comes to
reptiles
[Laughter]
no tolerance um
i'm pretty liberal
when it comes to let's see joe biden
fell off a bicycle good lord
what is the secret service letting that
guy in a [ __ ] bicycle for i swear to
god you literally have a president who
shouldn't even be driving and you're
going to stick him on a bicycle he's
getting one of those motorcycles that
has three wheels on it
good lord
i mean that's when you know you're old
when you forget how to ride a bicycle
you know that's you know something you
never forget oh you live long enough you
do
um so the i came out and the bird was
gone so um
god well i don't know what happened
maybe he had a tough landing maybe he
got just [ __ ] ate somebody's weed
which by the way man i gotta you know
can we when are they gonna do this study
about how a dictate addicting [ __ ]
weed is
my god
now that it's [ __ ] legal these people
that they're like [ __ ] raging
alcoholics you know like what a [ __ ]
booze bag just goes to work
and he's sipping drinks all day that's
what these [ __ ] potheads are doing
and they got they got it they can rub it
on their arm
like [ __ ] you know those steroids
people were taken in the early 2000s ah
that was it was cream
my muscles were sore so i put it on and
then the next day they were [ __ ] huge
and i had three home runs um
they got pens
they got edibles they got hair spray the
amount of ways that people can just be
[ __ ] high all day
wake and bake
lunch and brunch right because you're
high you eat both
and you know i'm just saying i'm just
saying the story's gonna come out
now i might be a hater
because i'm i'm a reformed
[ __ ] booze bag
i'm a reformed
gotta dweller
um i'm just saying watch out for that
[ __ ] everybody
you know
it's like like i feel like weed right
now is like what wine is
we're wine everybody's so talking about
like what you're pairing it with like
nobody notices you're drinking a bottle
a night
and weeds become the same thing if you
want to focus this is a good strain if
you just want to like chill i would do
this if you want to [ __ ] you know
like
clean your whole house and forget you
even did it i'd smoke this and eat one
of those
um
but i haven't said that
i don't know
do it up do whatever the [ __ ] you want
to do right
jesus pill you went hard and then you're
like yeah what am i gonna do you know
the [ __ ] do i know
maybe i'm just an old guy that's upset
that all of a sudden it's [ __ ] legal
and i'm too old to go to a rave
right
i never had any desire to go to a
[ __ ] rave
the original rave was woodstock which i
performed at this weekend i want to
thank everybody out there
um
and as amazing as that concert is i
always look at it going like there's no
[ __ ] way i would want to be there
even at a young age i would be over that
in four hours
four hours and then my car was stuck in
traffic and people are sliding around in
the mud and people are on [ __ ] acid
oh my god and where are you sleeping
right you're sleeping on the grass and
right as you finally go to sleep after
the last guy has his bad trip [ __ ]
jimi hendrix comes out with his guitar
[Music]
where hey jimmy
[ __ ] it give me another two hours
yeah
oh no hey jimmy can you do that yeah
that's my jimmy hendrix
impression
yeah he does it all the time
he sings purple haze he starts off yeah
um
he's a really agreeable guy that jimi
hendrix um but anyway um
i'm just [ __ ] around that was one of
my favorite gigs i've ever done at
woodstock
shout out to the chef
that works there this guy made me a
salad like
it's like they picked everything that
was in it
and then they had a little burrata on
top oh my god i didn't know what the
dressing was
it's like this is what a salad should be
if a salad was like this rather than
that [ __ ] they sell down there the
golden arches
ronald mcdonald
the original evil ginger out there
poisoning his own [ __ ] countrymen
um
he's the one you know they always say
that you know you know redheads like me
are the spawn of the devil
you know
and then if you write with your left
hand that's another thing i'm a
left-handed
[ __ ] redhead
all right ain't even i'm telling you
to watch out for ronald mcdonald okay
just
give him a wide berth
go down there every once in a while kiss
his white glove
what am i talking about um
anyway so i went out there and they gave
they were nice enough they actually gave
us a tour of the place
and on the other side of um
this little uh
amphitheater
oh [ __ ] sorry
got right off the plane and played with
the kids you know father's day father's
day stuff um
on the other side of the hill you guys
got to go if you can if you get have a
chance you got to go they have an
incredible museum
with all of this memorabilia i had to
blow through it because i had to like
you know get ready for my show but one
of the really cool things that i saw
there was they had um
they had uh this picture of
people supporting the troops in vietnam
a bunch of young people with american
flags
and it's like yeah where is this story
when they tell i'll talk about the 60s
they always talk about they act like all
young people
were against it and that type of [ __ ]
and i knew that wasn't true
because my parents you know are
conservative and they they were
supporting it
and thought the hippies were a bunch of
[ __ ] you know
loafers who didn't want to you know one
of the
advantages of freedom didn't want to
fight for it you know they they went
along with the
the company
at that point and other people went
against it i don't know
i'll tell you right now if i got a
[ __ ] draft card
i would have gone just because i would
have been too afraid to burn it
it's like
i don't want to be on the lam for the
rest of my life what am i going to do
i'm going to go to canada
[ __ ] eat at uh
a tim hortons for the rest of my life i
can't do it i'm too americanized
i gotta i can learn how to fix jeeps or
something that keeps me
out of the action
oh my god can you imagine that
can i just get out of going to a jungle
cause i'm [ __ ]
three quarters of an albino you're
really gonna stick me in there those
[ __ ] things are gonna eat me alive
i'm gonna come walking in there looking
like a red velvet cake to him
[Laughter]
no i just would have done drugs
would've done drugs and pointed the gun
at the tree line that's what i would
have done um
jesus christ what a [ __ ] time but
anyways you go through that museum you
kind of relive all of that all of that
stuff that was going on
uh back when they used to report on wars
before it just became the two propaganda
channels that we now have that somehow
pit us against each other we just scream
and eat that's what we do now now we
just yell at each other when we used to
yell at the government going hey what
the [ __ ] are you guys doing enough of
this [ __ ] now we just sort of scream at
each other oh gee bill did you figure it
out
breezing through a [ __ ] museum in
upstate new york well i think i did
um
but i really loved seeing that
that that was in that museum showing
young people with american flags saying
support the troops and stuff like that
that was really uh
it was like all right there's the other
half of the pie
now this is sort of put into uh
you know more of a
balanced perspective
as far as where
young people were back then but uh i got
to tell you man you've really got to go
there it was one of my favorite gigs i
ever did it was like the perfect
temperature the food was amazing the
people were amazing so friendly and they
gave us a tour and you actually they
took us to the hill the hill where the
actual concert was is like sacred ground
so nobody like walks on it or any of
that type of stuff but like
you just look at the hill and after all
the years you know my whole life seeing
footage of it like the hill is famous
and it's funny because it goes up and it
sort of dips and then goes up again and
if you look at pictures of the crowd the
crowd takes on the shape of the hill so
then the crowd's not there now you
actually see the grassy hill
and um they had all these amazing aerial
photos of like the the guy with the farm
right next door [ __ ] hated
everything that the the festival stood
for
um and said you weren't allowed you're
not allowed on a property so literally
you could it was an aerial photo there's
like a line
almost like a state and there's just
nobody on his property and right next
door
is like you know 500 000 [ __ ] people
it's pretty incredible so i really want
to thank them that was uh
fascinating
uh
and um
i don't know
i couldn't believe i was there and then
i went out and the crowd was awesome
the whole thing was amazing and the the
uh night before i performed in
wilkes-barre which i was calling wilkes
bar because it's spelled b-a-r-r-e
wilkes-barre
um
and those fans were incredible that was
a great gig
um beautiful beautiful
part of the country
um wilkes-barre you know get close
enough to philly if you want to get the
city thing and then you can be out there
and
just seem like there's probably a bunch
of great hiking and all that type of
stuff i don't know i'm really into like
trees and lakes and [ __ ] now that i live
in the uh the upper echelons of hell out
here in the [ __ ] desert
um and then the last night
we did uh another amphitheater which
musicians have told me they call them
sheds
so we played the pnc
whatever the [ __ ] it's called the last
time i was there
was on that legendary opium anthony uh
traveling virus tour
and i was actually thinking you know the
last time i was there i believe
three of the comics on there if not four
i want to say the lineup had bob saget
ralphie may patrice o'neal
and otto and george
um
unbelievable unbelievable and i went
down all of these memories came back
of that crazy tour
and um
i remember i looked out and i got that
same nervousness i had when you were
doing that tour because that was a
[ __ ] aggressive
actually they weren't the jersey crowd
was great but what happened
close to philly and camden everybody
kind of knew that that show was was
coming
so um
i don't know uh but anyway i went out i
had a great time and um
joey diaz
swang by
to say hello and i said hey you want to
go up and do some time he said i'd love
to so we brought him up first
and uh dean del rey took video of it
didn't it you know those [ __ ] cell
phones didn't do justice
of how [ __ ] crazy the crowd went
when um
when joey took the stage i told kenny to
say there's three
legends in new jersey
frank sinatra
bruce springsteen
and mad flavor joey coco diaz he [ __ ]
went out place went [ __ ] nuts
you know he comes out what's up
[ __ ] what exit you from you you
know
he just [ __ ] murdered
then brought dean out and then um
i came out to close it out and i could
not have had a better time so thank you
to everybody in all three of those
wilkes-barre woodstock and uh out there
in pnc park there in uh new jersey i
actually had a great time in new york
too
you know
it was uh it's a gay pride so it was
wall-to-wall gay dudes and i was
actually thinking you know gay dudes are
not nearly as [ __ ] aggressive
as they you when i was young they were
[ __ ] scared but then i was thinking
maybe i'm just old so nobody's [ __ ]
looking at me anymore
[Laughter]
my old fisherman beard
um
i'm talking like the early [ __ ] 80s
jesus christ
jesus christ you i don't know look
um anyway
plowing ahead here uh
so i had a great father's day um
i did my show and i i literally you know
had a pickup at like 5 a.m flew back on
like a 6 50 a.m flight
landed here around like 9 30.
came home you know my daughter made me a
card
you know we went we went swimming
my wife took me out
you know i smoked a cigar we laughed i
watched a little bit of the u.s open
which i you know ended up having to
leave because my uh
the sitter had to go so we ended up
coming back and i don't know who won
that thing but i saw that kid picked up
two strokes on one hole with two two
left i think
sank like a [ __ ]
i don't know looked like a like a 30
footer
i watched a little bit of the f1
i uh
max verstappen winning again but
ferrari coming in second but
lewis hamilton first time in months i
don't know if he maybe we got like a
third place in like march or april the
first time he's been on the podium in
months
and mercedes which you knew they were
we're going to get this [ __ ] together so
um
it's coming up on the the end of july
break for f1 the season's what like i
don't know 40 over
and all of a sudden they're getting
lewis hamilton's car dialed in
uh max verstappen has continued to win
he's got a sizable lead but jesus christ
it's going to be some [ __ ] sick
sick racing for the rest of the season
so i'm very excited that whatever the
[ __ ] was going on with lewis hamilton's
car
even though i root against him you know
i don't want to see one of the great
arguably the greatest driver ever riding
around a [ __ ] box right i want to see uh
i want to see verstappen go up against
them
so um
what else i do i caught up with a bunch
of people i did some sets in new york it
was awesome
uh my celtics lost to the golden state
warriors congratulations to golden state
um just amazing what they're doing up
there and um
you know what can you say about steph
curry
other than if steph curry didn't play
for golden state i don't think they win
ever
um i don't think they win anything i
mean that guy is
without a doubt the mvp man i mean that
guy just he brings it past the half
court line you're like ah [ __ ]
just don't follow them jesus christ
it'll be a four-point play
um
it was difficult to watch them drinking
champagne
in the boston garden took me back to 85.
said 85 or 87 when the lakers beat us
they
for the first time in the garden i think
it was 85
that was brutal to watch that was the
first time any team had ever drank
champagne in the boston garden
now it's just the td bank north garden
so drink up fellas
you know it's mentioned this on the
anything better podcast when they were
shown the next day the uh the locker
room celebration of the golden state
warriors
i was in the hotel gyms in uh westbury
and uh
club soda kenny was watching the tv
he's not a sports fan he was watching
them spraying champagne
and he saw that they had those ski
goggles on he was like they wear goggles
when they do
he goes just don't do it then
[Music]
it's [ __ ] hilarious
um
anyway so uh
man i had a good time in new york i
really wanna uh i swear i ran
hung out with a bunch of comics i hadn't
seen in a minute caught up with some
people you know as i mentioned i saw
american buffalo
and uh
i saw uh gerard carmichael's new special
that rathaniel which absolutely blew me
away beau byrne and the directing thing
that he did on that i really hope those
two
do some more [ __ ] together because that
was like
i can't remember the last time i watched
something like that
it was just absolutely riveting from the
beginning to the end it was a [ __ ]
masterpiece
um
and what else what else what else is
going on in my world oh i remember
i remember
uh old freckles finally pulled the
trigger and he ordered his [ __ ] ford
f250 and ain't gonna be here for nine
years with the backup but i ordered it
i ordered it and i got all the [ __ ]
bells and whistles
i finally presented an argument
that made my wife [ __ ] give me the
look but also kind of smiled
you know because i have the old 68 f-100
right so she goes to me i said i'm you
know
i'm busting my ass this movie's coming
together i got a huge [ __ ] tour all
right the old man's gonna buy his dream
truck she goes what are you getting and
i showed her the f250 pickup truck she
goes
you don't need another truck i looked at
her i go you don't need another bag
[Laughter]
she was walking out of the room she just
cocked her head and gave me the look and
i just laughed
i'm just like it's not gonna be here you
don't have to look at it
she thinks it's so [ __ ] stupid i know
she's right
you know
oh my god if you see this truck you're
like that guy knows how to build a house
from scratch
he must be towing a yacht down the
street that's the level i went with this
truck
uh but i got the f250 i didn't get the
[ __ ] you know
the limited the platinum the king ranch
i call those texas trucks
you know those guys they get shiny belt
buckle that you know
the back of their truck has never even
seen a bale of hay
those guys those city cowboys that drive
around the four-door pickup trucks not
that i wanted the f-250 with the [ __ ]
rubber mat floor the bench seat the way
i remembered him growing up
um
and front to back i just got every
[ __ ] thing i could get on that thing
the four-wheel drive
uh
everything
[ __ ] everything and uh i cannot wait
i just that's that's coming uh over the
horizon i got the biggest [ __ ] engine
i could get in it
it's gonna it's an apocalypse apocalypse
vehicle
and
it's hilarious my wife thinks it's the
stupidest thing
she doesn't get it what's hilarious i'm
like look at her son
look at how like his favorite toy is
this garbage truck his favorite thing in
the world is a garbage truck he sees a
fire engine he loses his mind he sees
trucks he loves them
it's it's she doesn't get it she doesn't
get it what's funny is my daughter's
wired the same way when i give you know
when i get my daughter a ride in my
truck right
she always says to me she goes dad she
goes this is the biggest truck in the
whole wide world and i'm like uh you
know i don't think it's the biggest it's
a nice one though and we'll drive by
trucks clearly i think i told you guys
the story she still feels no this one's
bigger
um
so my whole life since my like freshman
sophomore year
in high school i remember there was a
kid who had a uh he had an f250
four-wheel drive and he would go
four-wheeling it was green
and um
i just i don't know i've just always
liked uh
i mean i did like muscle cars and [ __ ]
like that i do like when you get like a
[ __ ] pickup and they give you [ __ ]
about like why'd you get a pickup it's
like why'd you get a sports car you're
not a
you're not gonna take it to the track
all these [ __ ] jerk-offs can go out
you can go and buy a [ __ ] ferrari
right what's that 300 grand
you can get a [ __ ] f-250
for like 50 grand
that's another thing that's what it's
like i just spent like [ __ ]
one-sixth
what some
aren't you happy that my dream car is 50
grand
ah jesus
the fact that that that was the there
was even any like
like pushback on that is is the one of
the things that it makes marriage so
goddamn funny you know
oh you don't want you don't want you
don't want that taken up the driveway
but you can take over three quarters of
the walk-in closet the bathroom the
bedroom and all of that [ __ ]
jesus christ enough with the
encroachment i should get that truck
pull in the driveway and throw all this
[ __ ] you don't need in the back of it
and take it to the dump now these are
things the old me used to say i'm not
gonna say that
there's no upside by the way shout out
to the [ __ ] stanley cup finals i know
that last one was a blowout
but those first two games i watched the
replays of them that's some of the best
[ __ ] hockey i've ever seen in my life
in my life i only wish tampa won one of
those overtime games because now the
series is just over
um
but uh
colorado avalanche jeez they look like
the [ __ ] 1980s edmonton oilers
it's the fastest [ __ ] team i've ever
seen in my life
um
unbelievable
but those first two games holy [ __ ]
i can't remember the last time i saw
playoff hockey at that level i hope you
guys all you [ __ ] uh
lower bowl nba
[ __ ] glitter douche bags you should
check that out you know i watch your
sport
you know
people running out shooting t-shirts
into the crowd everybody clap your hands
that [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] that is
oh it's such a travesty i wish i ran the
nba the level that i would dial it back
it's like can we get just back to the
fact that this is one of the most
beautiful games ever
and is played by some of the greatest
athletes all of all time can you get
these [ __ ] jerk-offs
off the [ __ ] court please
oh what i would do
if some stupid-ass celebrity came to the
[ __ ] game and had that look on their
face and they're not even cheering and
they're looking at their phone wearing
bedazzled clothes that's it you're out
we're gonna have bouncers get them the
[ __ ] out of there let's get some
degenerate gambler from [ __ ] up top
oh [ __ ] i actually riffed on this on the
anything better i'm overlapping here my
brain's so tired
i'm telling you
be such a better you want to see
something great
you ever watched that michael rappaport
documentary uh uh when the garden was
eaten
my big takeaway from that
aside from um
you know that fight
that i'd never seen the footage of
willis was it willis reed i'm bad with
nba back then
um
yeah willis reed had where he just beat
up a whole team
um
was when they would cut to the crowd
i mean it was it was just sports fans
it was sports fans no one was looking at
the camera
all right
it was just a sea of just [ __ ]
old-school bald guys
you know and everybody just like just
riveted screaming about the game nobody
miming nobody shooting a [ __ ] bow and
arrow
miming doing that
none of this [ __ ] other [ __ ] it was
just a goddamn game and an announcer and
these people look like i don't know
i'm not saying
it should go all the way back to that
but it'd be nice and i you could say
that really about all sports
once they got the luxury boxes and the
corporate [ __ ] started buying those
things up you know baseball has that
problem too
um
a lot of them do
like it's so ridiculous to watch a
yankee game and it never looks like it's
sold out because there's a bunch of wall
street [ __ ] instead of sitting in their
seats they're down below eating [ __ ]
prime rib
that's another one all right you came
here to eat just get the [ __ ] out of
here
get the [ __ ] out of here like this
should be a thing like if you leave your
seat too long somebody from the
mezzanine or the upper deck should be
able to come down
and cheer on the game
and heckle some guy in the on deck
circle from the other team the way it
used to be scare a couple of kids
you know
get yourself over served
yeah i had this idea
i don't know if this would work
i saw a motorcycle with a side car on it
right
and i was thinking like that would be
the greatest way
if you owned a bar
to bring home people that were over
served
there's always that one person they
don't want to give up the keys and then
you just [ __ ] just stick him in the
sidecar put some goggles on him if he
pukes you know what are you gonna do
just holds it off he's already
he's just he's already outside right
you take him home
you know he gets to put his arms up like
he's on a [ __ ] roller coaster you
know just
just have a good time take them home
it'd be funny it's like when somebody on
the red sox hits a home run and they put
them in that laundry basket and they
[ __ ] push them down the uh
the dugout this is the same way
i i don't know i think if you had a fun
way of bringing people home
maybe they could get out of their ego i
guess now uber solved all of that but
that would have been a great thing
hey listen buddy you're you're sidecar
level drunk right now okay we're taking
your keys dude you're gonna ride home
like
on a motorcycle you know sitting there
just enjoy it
you know you get the bed spins you puke
now puke before you get home we'll give
you some mouthwash and [ __ ] you can walk
in maybe your wife's asleep you can get
away with it i don't know i mean we're
really bending over backwards here to
try to work this out for you
um
all right
i will say that beautiful part of the
country i was just wilkes bear barry
woodstock and out in jersey um
i don't know man
i don't know there was a lot
i probably gonna retire back there
you know
i just every one of those roads i just
kept thinking of [ __ ] driving that
truck that i have coming down it
having a nice little house in the middle
of [ __ ] nowhere nobody bugs you
i don't even need to sound proof my drum
room because there's no neighbors
there's trees there's water
everything doesn't catch on fire it's
like you know there's something to be
said about that
um
all right what do we got here let's do a
little uh
so don't let anybody ever tell you uh
you know you live in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere all these [ __ ]
hollywood douchebags are the people who
live on the east coast and call these
states flyover states and [ __ ] like that
or the boonies
um
i don't know man you know i know there's
a lot of lunatics out there
you know that drive around like the
american flag hanging off their [ __ ]
truck like people don't know what
country they're in
um there's a lot to be said about living
out there
um all right simply safe everybody
something
everybody wants to be uh today's episode
of monday morning podcast is brought to
you by simply safe home security i
believe home should be the safest place
on earth for every family that's why i
use and recommend simply safe i got the
whole system man
i can see 360 all around my whole house
it's fantastic um simply safe is
advanced whole uh is advanced whole home
security that puts you your home and
your family's safety first here's why i
love it simply safe offers comprehensive
protection not only against intruders
and burglary but against
expensive home hazards
uh from flooding to fires with 24 7
professional monitoring simply safes
agents take action the moment a thread
is detected dispatching police or first
responders in an emergency even if
you're not home simply safe uses
proprietary video verification
technology so that monitoring agents can
visually confirm the threat in order to
get higher priority 911 dispatch so
basically if you say there's a guy
outside my house with the [ __ ] axe
they can confirm it and they send the
swat team they send the anti-axe guys
down there monitoring plans are
affordable prices just a buck a day
dollar a day with no long-term contract
or hidden fees because feeling safe at
home shouldn't break the bank you can
customize the perfect system for your
home in just a few minutes at
simplysafe.com uh go today and claim a
free indoor security camera plus twenty
percent off with interactive monitoring
go to
uh
simplysafe.com that's
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
[Music]
all right what do we got next oh look
who it is everybody jesus christ oh
jesus it's all zip
[Music]
zip recruiter everybody
talk about some things you're looking
forward to enjoying this summer being a
couple days closer to having my [ __ ]
truck i don't need showing up whoa
uh examples pool time a family or
personal vacation backyard barbecues
with friends redoing your deck gardening
i know what i'm looking forward to
somebody power washing my driveway and
these [ __ ]
patio bricks around uh the backyard get
all that water stains off of there i
become obsessed with that i literally
follow people on instagram that power
wash walkways
um
that's why you need zip recruiter to
find great candidates
that's why because i want to power wash
my driveway uh they do the work for you
and now you can try it for free at zip
yeah dot com slash bird zip recruiter
uses its powerful technology to find and
match the right candidates
up with your job
you can easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply additionally ziprecruiter has a
complete suite of tools that makes it
easier to filter review and rate your
candidates four to five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
no wonder zip
gosh yes yes
that was the devil version is the number
one rated hiring site based on g2
satisfaction's
uh ratings as of january 1st 2020
so soak up all that's all summer has to
offer and let zip recruiter do the work
for you ready for the url it's
ziprecruiter.com that's where you can
try it for free again that's it
yeah dot com slash burr
z-i-p-r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r
i know you guys are dumb like me z-i-p
r-e-c-r-u-i
that's where it goes off the rails for
me t-e-r the smartest way to hire
um
why do i have two simply safe reads here
and drew
and drew
it's the exact same one oh you know what
it's not andrew's fault it's not his
fault i didn't paste i did it twice
i'm a [ __ ]
all right
here we go let's where are we we got
some quiet some we got some people
writing in
we got
questions here alicia keys
uh afternoon billy bistro tits
you know people
i've been going to the gym for a couple
of months right now and i'm telling you
i'm getting my [ __ ] revenge body back
all right when i get out there in my
two-piece bikini this this summer okay i
think these these these insults are
gonna stop all right just listen to your
podcast from thursday and wanted to
quickly say that what you were talking
about regarding alicia keys
i was saying is that really her last
name what are the odds her last names
are keys
and she ends up being a grammy
award-winning piano play pianist
uh he said it's called
nominative nominative god
i hate like more than three syllables
nominative that's why i could never
[ __ ] hang with italians i was good
with the first name nino right and then
you get to the second ah jesus
a lot of vowels uh determinism
nominative determinism
that that's how you say basically the
idea that someone called john bread is
almost destined to become a baker or
edward scissorhands becoming a barber
um he should have been called edward
pooper scooper if he knew who the [ __ ]
he was going to be dating years later
now
now i've written
now i've written it now that i've
written it i realized how unbelievably
dull this email is no it isn't that's
like um
envisioning
whatever that success thing
that people have jesus christ if i see
one more stupid celebrity
posting a [ __ ] video trying to
inspire me
what what at what point did all of these
people become qualified
like what makes you [ __ ] qualified
why because you twirl around on a
[ __ ] stage nobody gives a [ __ ] and
nobody asks you shut the [ __ ] up
um now i've written he says i realize
how unbelievably dull this email is but
i've always wanted to write in just to
say how much i enjoy the podcast and
also how valuable i can imagine me
actually doing this as you guys write in
to me for advice to actually criticize
other people doing the exact same thing
and also how valuable some of the things
that you say about your parenting has
been for me oh look at that
wait a minute
am i an influencer
uh more than once you've made me look at
myself and consider the impact of my
actions on my daughter wow keep on
keeping on yeah that's why i kind of
laid off the nba finals when i saw my
daughter looking at me when we were
playing candyland and i'm screaming
about the refs going on of course there
here come here we go every game this is
what they do and she's looking at me
like who the [ __ ] is this guy
i was like all right she doesn't need to
see that guy
not now not ever
taping the games watching them
when she goes to sleep all right eating
berries in a survival situation i love
[ __ ] like this by the way
all right now i know you guys know that
i'm a big time liberal all right i will
not [ __ ] anywhere unless it says gender
neutral
something whatever the [ __ ] else you're
supposed to say uh peaceful warrior
social justice guy
um eating berries in a survival
situation which make may make some of
you uh you know
you redneck type people you know
you guys with your lawnmower engines
hooked up to your [ __ ] ac to keep it
going you know you're off the grid guys
i want to hear from you guys
and the ladies too okay
that's a saying there's not a lady out
there that doesn't know how to [ __ ]
hotwire a dodge ram
uh eating berries in a survival
situation dear bill bear
bill bear gryllsburg
is this supposed to be a grizzly bear
g-r-y-l-l-s burr i don't get it i'm old
sorry i'm sure it was great um on
monday's podcast you briefly mentioned
you're not eating
mention not eating berry berries as
they're poisonous
magical i was talking about there's
berries
is it barry bush
if i say that [ __ ] word one more time
um
at the end of my driveway and
you know they look edible but i know not
to eat berries because some of them are
poisonous this person said you are
mainly correct eating berries when you
can't identify them can cause serious
issues
up to and including
death i've went through the air force
s-e-r-e school survival evasion
resistance escape
dude you got your money's worth
when this [ __ ] hits the fan you got air
force training on survival evasion
resistance escape survival staying alive
evasion avoiding
the zombies
resistance chopping their [ __ ] heads
off escaping getting the [ __ ] out of
there before they eat your neck
fantastic
anyway and he says they uh he or she
says and they teach
wilderness survival as part of the
curriculum alum
another big word curriculum
hey check this out
attach a case
attache
i could say it
finally could say it always i always say
ash chate
briefcase man uh the final part of this
portion is where they dump you this is
the final part of this guy's training
where they dump you in a remote part of
idaho the idaho national forest
oh man there's bears there's mountain
lions bobcats [ __ ] snakes with few
with a few other people and you have to
navigate and evade people
that are looking for you with minimal
supplies
basically no food when it comes to
berries look for dark berries about 99
of berries are edible without negative
effects see now there you go
there's some quality information
for comparison only about 50 of red
berries are edible and the majority of
other berries white yellow green etc are
poisonous to humans
oh there you go i don't think i would
ever eat a white yellow or green i would
think that they weren't ripe yet but if
i was hungry enough i'd eat it
anyway hope this info comes in handy if
you ever get lost on a hike you ginger
[ __ ]
all the best and go [ __ ] yourself well
thank you for writing in
thank you for your service hey and why
don't you thank me
huh for my tax dollars that puts you in
that [ __ ] forest out there i'm a hero
too
uh what is there to do in albuquerque
dear bill i'm a 51 year old female hey a
lady
i love when the ladies finally write in
i wonder why they don't oh cause i'm a
misogynistic [ __ ] i'm a 51 year old
female ups driver in southwest kansas i
listen to your pot jesus christ talk
about the last vehicle you want to be in
in tornado alley is driving that [ __ ]
thing
how quickly you're going to get
nice little crosswind you're done i
listen to your podcast when i'm working
so i don't have to listen to my thoughts
i love this person thanks for helping me
get through the day i'll do my very best
to put the punctuation where they belong
so your head doesn't explode
uh when i was in the fifth grade i was
sent to the reading trailer
so i feel your pain when it comes to
reading oh is that what they had a
trailer
oh no
and that's out in kansas so there wasn't
any [ __ ] trees there it was just
right out there in the open i appreciate
your common sense approach when it comes
to persuading others to consider another
view i'm married to a ginger who wears
sunblock religiously good for him he's
my rock long story short
he's my third husband
um and i wish i would have calmed the
[ __ ] down in my first marriage uh my
second ex-husband is in prison
wait he's my third husband and i wish i
would have calmed the [ __ ] down in my
first marriage oh you see saying you
[ __ ] up your first one the second one
was a lunatic
um i said my second
my second ex-husband is in prison
i wonder what he did i remind myself of
a puppy that just chews the hell out of
everything but finally is able to sit on
the porch and appreciate life
you know is there anything better than
an adult actually
just owning up to hey you know
the bet i'm laying and i basically made
um anyway she says i'm taking my 12 year
old grandson on the train to albuquerque
for a few days do you have any
suggestions on where to go or what to do
with a 12 year old
no
um i only went out there to do stand-up
gigs and i used to do breaking bad out
there and i would land and go right to
wardrobe and i would go to work i mean
that was one of the greatest and most
efficient sets i was ever on
and
usually i'm barnstorming through i did
go up to santa fe one time
we shot up there that was a blast
um well i would think that there's
incredible hiking i know they do that
hot air balloon thing if you're into
that
take some dirt bikes out there's a lot
of stuff to do in nature and then i
would think there's a ton of like uh
native american stuff you can check out
i will tell you this it's one of the
most beautiful states i've ever been in
and one of the most fascinating things
about it is you can see the weather
coming
like you can see a rainstorm off in the
distance or whatever you know um
i wish i had more i i haven't been to
albuquerque that many times but
i mean i know there's a lot of good bars
there i don't think you're taking your
12 year old there but there's plenty of
great food i would think the mexican is
[ __ ] incredible there
uh that's where i would start they also
have all like these websites and stuff i
would do that but i think it's really
cool um
i remember going uh to the grand canyon
vegas and in uh
los angeles
with my grandmother and we had a blast
we had a [ __ ] blast so that's really
cool that you're doing that um
all right what else do we got here uh
sorry i wish i could have given you more
advice um
do i have my phone with me though
i do i have a little thing in my phone
called places to go
so every time
i
you know go somewhere
i know the places to go jesus christ
that's how [ __ ] basic my brain is
i have all these lists of restaurants
and all of this [ __ ] and stuff to do and
all of that
in my phone i'm scrolling right now i'm
looking for
maybe new mexico i'd have another rhode
island seattle st louis
looks like we blew by it then i go to
australia
canada europe all right wait a second i
don't have anything
come on
gotta have something
new orleans new jersey new haven new
york yeah it's under
cities and
states
let's look up
albuquerque albert jerky there
albuquerque
i don't know i know they have some
incredible you want to take some ufc
classes
um
i know they got some a lot of champions
come
from what did they call it
something city god damn it
this woman said it too and she was a
badass
duke city or something like that i
forget what i was just like say i'm not
[ __ ] i mean i gotta go around [ __ ]
with people but anyway um sorry i wish i
could anybody has any ideas just
write in and i'll i'll do it on the next
podcast anybody from albuquerque
listening where should this person go
there we go i'm gonna phone a friend on
this one all right what do we got here
um
girlfriend gave me an ultimatum
ah jesus christ
why are they you know why is it always
like a [ __ ] hostage situation you
know what i mean
i swear to god
whenever they give me an ultimatum you
know what they should do they should
just for the fun of it you should make
them like do it from outside your
apartment like with a bullhorn leading
on the hood of a car like one of those
old-school 70s like dog day afternoon
attention mark
you have three months to get me a ring
or i'm gonna start [ __ ] all your
friends
i know you're in there
uh girlfriend gave me an ultimatum uh
dear mr billy frecklenuts
i've been in a pretty good relationship
for about five months now and she's
already given you an ultimatum you must
be drinking your ass off
i'm 25 years old and she is 23. before
we got into a relationship i have
expressed wholeheartedly that my dream
in life is to be a professional wrestler
she is supportive of that okay
everything's good so far and you picked
a [ __ ]
you're going after a dream
you don't just become a professional
wrestler so
first and foremost good luck with your
dream
um she's supportive of that and is even
considering following me
to live downstate so i can go to a good
training facility down there to me
wrestling acting entertaining are the
same fields part of my dream is to cross
over into movies
oh i see what you're gonna do you're
gonna blow up on the wwe become this big
personality
and then then do like uh what the rock
and uh john cena did
that's amazing all right i like the game
plan anyway it seems very realistic
very realistic as many wwe superstars
have done it and i believe wrestling is
a good stepping stone i agree the other
day i received a message from someone
making an independent romantic comedy
film
where i live and would like me to be one
of the main characters i believe it
would help me gain
experience and get a network with people
who also enjoy acting i was so excited
to tell my girlfriend and when i did she
immediately shot me down
she was saying that she does not want me
to act in anything that involves romance
and that she wouldn't want
me acting in any roles that involve
kissing sex scenes or even holding hands
on screen she says she's compromised
by letting me take roles
she says that oh she says she
compromises by letting me take roles
that don't involve those actions
i personally think those restrictions
are very limiting
to roles i could audition for or aspired
to be in even forrest gumps get it gets
his rocks off she gave me an ultimatum
of basically respecting your boundaries
or sacrificing part of my dream
any advice you have on this topic would
be great i have great advice [ __ ] that
take the role go do it
you're 25. you got your whole life ahead
of you she's 23. i mean her brain isn't
even fully developed yet she doesn't
know what she's saying
all right i went a little hard there
yeah don't do that dude
like i'm getting anxiety i don't even
know you i'm getting anxiety that you're
not gonna take that role take the
[ __ ] role
that's it and you just be nice about
just say listen
i understand your boundaries i respect
your boundaries but
they
i mean i i don't know what to tell you i
want to act and they're giving me a role
here and part of acting
is stuff like this and
you know it's
great to know three months in that
you're not in on it so i don't you know
what what the what the [ __ ] are we doing
here
all right that was terrible the way i
just said that
i just i don't know how to do this i
this just you just got you know you just
got to go
is there a a a
nice blunt way
just say this is too big an opportunity
for me to turn down i'm gonna take the
role and then wait to see what she says
and anyways dude what did you say
earlier you said something you said
something yeah you know
i'm in a pretty good relationship you
don't love this person
all right
dude you're you're about ready to get on
a [ __ ] rocket ship
okay
you're gonna go [ __ ] you're wrestling
you're gonna be in movies and all of
this [ __ ] i mean you gotta you gotta
have
[ __ ] you gotta dive in the deep end
you just gotta jump in dude
and
you can't let anything stop you
especially some petty [ __ ] like this
all right um
yeah and who knows maybe if you just say
well i'm doing it
maybe she comes along i don't know i can
just tell you right on it right out of
the [ __ ] gate the fact that she's
[ __ ] saying
that you know she's put she's already
putting a governor on this [ __ ]
this is actually a great thing that this
happened this early on and once again
the fact that you say it's a pretty good
relationship
you're not saying this is love my life i
want to marry her i can see having kids
with this person you say it's a pretty
good relationship
you know
dude the level of regret i'm just
guessing the level of regret you'll have
if you don't [ __ ] you got to take it
you got to take it don't
don't [ __ ] this up all right take the
[ __ ] gig okay and let her have a
little [ __ ] pout let her go storm off
whatever the [ __ ] it is she's gonna do
you go do the goddamn gig all right you
do the [ __ ] gig you get priceless
you know
priceless experience
okay
then you go downstate or whatever the
[ __ ] you said and go down and start
training and you're off and running and
you never look back okay and she either
wants to come along or she doesn't but
that's it but either way whether she
goes or she doesn't is you're going
okay there's your advice all right so as
bad as the albuquerque ones i think i
think i did it right on that other one
all right
there you go
um she's gonna be like i don't want you
like wrestling
where there's you know women
wrestling you know i don't know if they
do the [ __ ] co-ed thing now but every
once in a while you see some woman get
body slammed by a guy
you had you like your hand you're her
crotch when you picked her up
just like yeah jesus christ i'm out
there i'm dropped her i'm i'm [ __ ]
dressed like a viking it's not real
um all right that is the podcast
everybody once again congratulations to
the golden state warriors moving into
third place all time i believe
uh
most championships they got the bulls
next
um
and then who's next it really should be
the lakers if they if they gave a [ __ ]
the nba gave his [ __ ]
um
but somehow with their funny math
they're tied with the celtics which is
just [ __ ] hilarious to me all right
that's it go [ __ ] yourselves i'll check
in on you on thursday